[Applause]
[Music]
you don't want to do this stop Clark
this is over
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Arthur don't do this you don't want to
follow Clarke I'm not following anyone
you've never understood Atlantis Bruce
we are in ancient people with an
old-fashioned sense of justice
Batman knew they'd double-cross him we
have to move
[Applause]
there's no escape
you wish to fall so be it
[Music]
go back to conduct Adam stay here and
you'll be prosecuted
you'd have to capture me Batman the dive
administered the last time all that
ancient wisdom wasted
Supergirl where are you they're
following me lead them to the cave
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she led us right to him
it's no accident you brought us here of
course it isn't I warned him about Diana
but I didn't believe you'd turn on me
this is the last time Bruce no more
secrets no more schemes schemes I'm not
the one who stoked Clark's worst fears
[Music]
to pacify man's world kal needed steel
not compassion what you didn't bring
peace you started a war
war is over fighting on the same side it
felt like old times but I guess we both
knew it would end this way
do you remember that night
when you told me Louis was pregnant you
knew even before I said anything that
was a good memory from another lifetime
I miss the people we were then
me too
when Bruce you can't win you of all
people know Clark I never quit
this he he'll be out for a while I'm
sorry Cara for what
I couldn't save him
[Music]
Cara it's safe now
even without my powers the Phantom Zone
can't hold me
I'll be back we'll be ready
[Music]
I don't I wish
we were family Cara we still are I hope
someday you'll see that
[Music]
are you alright
no this symbol should give people hope
[Music]
he made them fear it that symbols
meaning is up to the person who wears it
when Clark and I founded the Justice
League we didn't govern people we
protected them plain and simple maybe
the world could use a team like that
again welcome to the circle of trust
[Music]
you
[Music]